JOINING US TONIGHT FOR THE HOUR,
SARA CARTER AND CHARLIE KIRK.
JUST LOOK AT WHAT THEY’VE DONE,
THERE IT IS, CONFIRMED BY THE
OFFICIAL GDP DATA THIS WEEK.
YET ANOTHER DISASTER, BROUGHT TO
YOU BY THE ESTABLISHMENT.
THE BIGGEST ECONOMIC COLLAPSE IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
YES CHINA AFFECTED THE WORLD
WITH ITS VIRUS, THEY KNEW HOW
BAD IT WAS BUT COVERED IT UP.
THEY STOPPED TRAVEL WITHIN CHINA
BUT DELIBERATELY ALLOWED TRAVEL
OUTSIDE OF CHINA UNTIL PRESIDENT
TRUMP SHUT IT DOWN.
WE TALK ABOUT REPARATION AND YOU
SOUGHT NOT JUST HERE FOR RACIAL
INJUSTICE BUT RIGHT NOW FROM
CHINA TO THE WORLD FOR THE VIRUS
CRIMES.
CHINA MUST PAY FOR WHAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT DID IN A CATASTROPHIC
DAMAGE THEY CAUSED.
BUT ONCE THE VIRUS WAS HERE, THE
RESPONSIBILITY LAY WITH OUR
LEADERS AND WHAT A COMPLETE AND
UTTER MESS THEY MADE OF IT.
RIGHT FROM THE START, WE TOLD
YOU THE TRUTH ABOUT THIS VIRUS,
MOST PEOPLE HAVE NOTHING TO
FEAR, THE RIGHT RESPONSE IS TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE, THE MASS
SHUT DOWN FOR A MASSIVE MISTAKE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE HAD THE
RIGHT INSTINCTS, RIGHT FROM THE
START.
BUT THE MEDIA, MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT, THE POLITICAL
ESTABLISHMENT, THEY DID NOT HAVE
A CLUE, FUELED BY MISINFORMATION
AND HYPE FROM THE TRUMP HATING
MEDIA.
JUST AS WERE SEEN WITH THE
BRAINLESS AND RECKLESS OBSESSION
WITH CASE NUMBERS, THE DOCTORS
TOOK TO THE AIRWAVES TO INSIST
THAT EVERYTHING BE SUBORDINATED
TO THE ONE SINGLE OBJECTIVE OF
TRYING TO STOP ANYONE BEING
INFECTED, WHAT LUNACY THIS WAS,
INFLICTED ON AMERICA, BUT A
MEDIA MEDICAL COMPLEX IN LOVE
WITH THE SOUND OF ITS OWN PANIC.
IN THE FIRST WORLD WAR, THE
BRAVE SOLDIERS SAID TO THEIR
DEATHS BY IDIOT GENERALS WHO
WERE DESCRIBED AS LIONS LED BY
DONKEYS.
TODAY WITH THE DOCTORS FALLING
IN LINE BEHIND THE MEDIA
DECEPTION, IT’S DONKEYS LED BY
LIARS.
WHAT ON EARTH WERE WE DOING,
ALLOWING THE DOCTORS TO TAKE
OVER THE COUNTRY AS THE FRENCH
PHILOSOPHER AND ACTIVIST PUT IT
THIS WEEK, YES AMERICA I’M GOING
TO QUOTE A FRENCH PHILOSOPHER
BECAUSE THIS GUY IS BANG ON THE
MONEY, THE DOCTORS ARE JUST
PEOPLE, THEY JUST DON’T KNOW,
THEY CANNOT BE INVESTED WITH
AUTHORITY UNDER THEIR WHITE
COATS, THEY ARE NAKED AND LIKE
YOU AND ME.
PEOPLE KEEP SAYING THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC, IT IS
NOT TRUE, THERE SEEMS TO BE AN
INTENTION OF COLLECTIVE DESIRE
TO PANIC.
IT IS NOT A BIG AS A DISASTER AS
WE THINK, THERE IS A UNILATERAL
FOCUS, COVID, COVID, COVID.
HE SAYS WE MUST RESIST THE WIND
OF MADNESS BLOWING OVER THE
WORLD.
YES WE MUST.
BECAUSE THE COST OF THE MADNESS,
THE HUMAN COST IS NOW
ASTRONOMICAL UNITS BORN NOT BY
THE DOCTORS, NOT BY THE MEDIA
FAN BOYS AND GIRLS, OR THE
POLITICIANS MAKING IT UP AS THEY
GO ALONG BUT MAINLY BY THE
POOREST AMERICANS, WORKING
AMERICANS, BLACK AND HISPANIC
AMERICANS, THE VERY PEOPLE THAT
ARE SHUT DOWN FANATICS SAYING
THEY SPEAK FOR BUT THEY
OBVIOUSLY DON’T.
HERE IS THE SHUT DOWN TOLL, OVER
17 MILLION STILL OUT OF WORK, AT
ONE POINT IT WAS 40 MILLION.
OVER $41000 PER TAXPAYER AND
GOVERNMENT SPENDING, OVER
100,000 SMALL BUSINESSES SHUT
DOWN FOR GOOD AND THE HUMAN
TOLL, THE MEDICAL HEALTH
CATASTROPHE IN THE DISASTROUS
EFFECTS OF LONG-TERM POVERTY AND
LIFE EXPECTANCY, WHAT DID YOU
ALL ACHIEVE, PRACTICALLY
NOTHING.
YOU SAW SIMILAR DEATH RATES IN
COUNTRIES THAT HAD NO SHUT DOWN
IN COUNTRIES THAT HAD EVEN
TOUGHER SHUTDOWNS.
DR. FAUCI SAYS THE VIRUS SPREAD
BECAUSE WE ONLY LOCKED DOWN 50%
OF THE COUNTRY.
WHAT?
SO HE WANTS TO SEE 80 MILLION
UNEMPLOYED, 200,000 SMALL
BUSINESSES GO BUST, TWICE AS
MANY MEDICAL OPERATIONS CANCEL,
TWICE AS MOST DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
TWICE AS MUCH SUBSTANCE ABUSE,
TWICE AS MUCH CHILD ABUSE,
HAVEN’T WE SUFFERED ENOUGH
DR. FAUCI.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THESE PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY’RE
DOING.
DR. FAUCI IS FOLLOWING AN OLD
PLAYBOOK FOR A DIFFERENT
DISEASE.
DOCTOR DEATH AND DESTRUCTION,
THE CDC ROBERT REDFIELD SCREWED
UP TEST FOR MONTHS WITH HIS
BUREAUCRATIC BUNGLING.
VAIN GOVERNORS AROUND THE
COUNTRY, LUXURIATED IN THE
LIMELIGHT OF DAILY PRESS
BRIEFINGS WHERE THEY LUDICROUSLY
PRETENDED THEY COULD MICROMANAGE
MOTHER NATURE WITH THEIR ABSURD
STAGES AND GATING CRITERIA.
WHAT HUBRIS, ARROGANCE, WHAT
IDIOTS.
THEY TOLD US HOW CAREFULLY THEY
WOULD LIFT RESTRICTIONS AND RIP
THEM OFF AND THREW THEM TO THE
WIND WHEN IT WAS A POLITICAL
PROTEST.
THEY FAVORED.
THEY TOLD US IT WAS ALL ABOUT
FLATTENING THE CURVE WITHOUT
TELLING US YOU END UP WITH THE
SAME OUTCOMES REGARDLESS.
WE SAID FROM THE START, THE
SHUTDOWNS ARE POINTLESS, THE
VIRUS WILL COME BACK THE MINUTE
YOU OPEN UP, SURE ENOUGH, AROUND
THE WORLD, CASES ARE RISING
EVERYWHERE, THE LOCKDOWNS ARE
BEING LIFTED, IT WAS ALL JUST AN
ILLUSION.
THERE WAS NO GOVERNOR IN CONTROL
OF EVENTS, THOSE CAREFULLY
CALIBRATED PUBLIC HEALTH
STRATEGIES DESIGNED BY THE
EXPERTS TO KEEP US SAFER BECAUSE
THEY NEVER TELL A SAFETY IS A
TOP PRIORITY, THEY WERE A JOKE.
INEFFECTIVE, COUNTERPRODUCTIVE,
THE WORST, NEW YORK CUOMO SENT
THOUSANDS TO THE DEATHS AS A
DELIBERATE POLICY CHOICE WITH
HIS DISASTROUS NURSING HOME
ORDER.
ALL IN ALL, THIS IS THE BIGGEST
PUBLIC POLICY DISASTER IN
HISTORY.
AND STILL THEY PRESS ON,
DEMENTED LEE MAKING IT WORSE,
NOW WE HAVE THE STUPID REOPENING
RULES, THE PSEUDOSCIENTIFIC
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES, THE
POINTLESS TEMPERATURE CHECKS,
THE TIME WASTING HEALTH
QUESTIONNAIRES, THE RANDOM
CAPACITY LIMITS, 25%, 33%, 50%,
ALL OF IT, NONSENSE FROM AN OUT
OF TOUCH CORPORATE AND
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATIC ELITE.
SWEEP IT AWAY.
ALL OF IT.
REOPEN SCHOOL, REOPEN THE
ECONOMY EVERYWHERE WITH ONE
EXCEPTION, AS WE SAID ALL ALONG
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE, TO DO
THAT, GET THE DATA ON WHO IS
VULNERABLE.
PRECISE DATA ON WHO HAS ACTUALLY
DIED, WHAT EXACTLY DO WE MEAN
WHEN WE SAY UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS.
IT IS A SCANDAL, TOTAL NATIONAL
SCANDAL THAT WE STILL DO NOT
HAVE THIS INFORMATION FROM
DR. FAUCI, WHAT HAS HE BEEN
DOING APART FROM SMUGGLING AND
LAPPING UP THE ADMIRATION OF THE
UNCRITICAL MEDIA.
AND AFTER ALL THIS, GUESS WHO
WANTS TO GIVE DR. FAUCI EVEN
MORE POWER, JOE BIDEN.
WITH TYPICALLY HUMILIATING AND
PANDERING TO HIS MEDIA
CHEERLEADERS.
BIDEN CONFIRMS, HE WILL MAKE
EVERYTHING EVEN WORSE WITH BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRATS THEY WOULD BE
EVEN MORE BOGUS BUREAUCRACY AND
SHUTDOWN STUPIDITY.
AND THAT TERRIFYING PROSPECT
GETS CLOSER EVERY DAY BECAUSE OF
THE BAFFLING COMPLACENCY OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, WHERE IS THE
ENERGY, WHERE ARE THE IDEAS IN
THE HOPE FOR THE FUTURE, TWO
WEEKS AGO WE WERE PROMISED
EXCITING POLICY ANNOUNCEMENTS IN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS.
WE ARE STILL WAITING.
HERE IS THIS WEEK’S CAMPAIGN
MEMO.
YOU DON’T WIN ELECTIONS WITH
FACEBOOK ADS OR DIGITAL STRATEGY
OR WHATEVER.
SURE, THEY CAN HELP BUT YOU WIN
ELECTIONS WITH IDEAS ABOUT THE
FUTURE, WHAT YOU WILL DO FOR
PEOPLE, THE CHANGES YOU WILL
BRING.
WE DON’T SEE ANY OF THAT FROM A
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THEY ARE
SLEEPWALKING INTO A BIDEN
PRESIDENCY IN A TOTAL CALAMITY
AND A DEMOCRAT TAKEOVER, HOUSE,
SENATE, LAW, UNCONSTRAINED POWER
TO LEFT-WING AGENDA EVER PUT
BEFORE THEY MAKE A PEOPLE BY
MAJOR PARTIES.
WAKE UP, WE NEED TO SEE A MAJOR
TRUMP POLICY ANNOUNCEMENT OR
POLICY SPEECH EVERY WEEK BETWEEN
NOW AND NOVEMBER, NOTHING ELSE
WILL DO.
GET ON WITH IT OR THE COUNTRY